how does your journey attend you seek
that which would bestow upon you the
right to rule the quest to reclaim a
homeland and slay a dragon
do not think I won't kill him
when did we allow evil to become
stronger than us
it is not our fight
it is a fight
but some doctors there
such is the nature of evil
in time all foul things on full
you waken that beast you'll discuss all
was that an earthquake that my lad was a
dragon
hey youtubers it's Charlie what did you
think of the desolation of smaug trailer
honestly I was really excited when I
heard this was coming just because I
really wanted to hear Benedict
Cumberbatch speak as the voice of Smaug
but honestly I think we're gonna have to
wait to one of the further trailers to
really hear him don't you really just
feel like smag is the real star of this
movie even though we don't really meet
him till the end of it if you saw Peter
Jackson's the live stream for desolation
of smaug earlier this year you actually
saw some of the locations and some of
the new characters were going to meet
let's talk about some of the new people
we saw in the teaser obviously Thranduil
isn't a new character he was in the
first movie just a little bit but really
we actually get to meet him in this
movie he's actually Legolas his father
in this movie so it's actually really
cool they live near Mirkwood that's also
where we meet Evangeline Lilly's
character Torrio she's actually a Peter
Jackson original they said that they
included her in the movie just to
balance out all the way there are
actually some complaints against the
inclusion of her character but i'll talk
about them in a future video we also got
a nice shot of Stephen Fry as the master
of Laketown even though he's pretty
unrecognizable but let's talk about some
of the sequences of events and the way
things are going to unfold in the movie
especially for people who haven't read
the hobbit in a while so the first
person they meet in the movie is played
by mikael persbrandt he's actually
playing a shape changer the only thing
he can really change into as a giant
bear so he's not quite on the level of
odo from deep space nine but he's still
pretty cool and then next obviously
everybody remembers the spiders of
Mirkwood they're a really big part of
the story and I feel like they're so
iconic that you just can't forget them I
don't know about you but I used to have
some nightmares about them every once in
a while when I was a little kid it's
actually Thranduil shelves that rescue
them from the spiders and then take them
to their home instead of being like the
elves where Elrond lives these are wood
elves of Mirkwood is their home even
though it's been taken over by the
spiders they also meet Orlando Bloom but
he's not really a part of the hobbit so
he's not going to travel with them in
the movie it's actually a big conflict
between the dwarves and the elves that
actually gets really bad after they kill
smog and they get all the treasure let's
just say elves are greedy too after they
leave the elves they travel to lake town
to get the supplies they need on their
way to the Lonely Mountain Stephen Fry
basically ends up extorting a lot of
stuff out of them just because
everyone's very aware of all the
treasure that's in the mountain the next
person they meet is actually
more interesting because he's a much
bigger part of the story bard the Bowman
is actually played by Luke Evans he was
actually in Peter Jackson's live stream
he actually lives much closer to the
mountain and in the story spoiler alert
careful he's actually the one that lands
the killing blow on smog bard the Bowman
is actually a lot like the dwarves and
that smog is basically destroyed his
homeland he's actually a former king
like aragorn who's living in exile
except that he's not wandering around in
the wilderness smog basically just
shattered their homeland so he basically
wants revenge just as bad as the dwarves
if you remember Luke Evans was also the
villain in the Fast and Furious 6 movie
isn't it only natural that he fight two
dragons I mean isn't Dwayne Johnson just
like a dragon I mean it's about as big
as one right the big bummer is that we
won't really get a lot of the close-up
shots of Smaug until the final parts of
the movie but if you saw in the trailer
Martin Freeman actually is sitting in
the gold pile so we will definitely see
him up close and we will definitely hear
him speak think of his voice is being
like Benedict Cumberbatch and Sherlock
before his morning tea just really
pissed off really low but one of the big
things about smog is is that he's famous
for being really arrogant so it's not
really a spoiler to assume that they're
going to use that to kill him before the
next trailer comes be sure and reread
the hobbit or at least the parts of it
that are going to be covered in this
movie it'll give you a good map of how
things are going to go Peter Jackson
does a really good job of staying as
close to the original text as possible
but honestly since they expanded this
into three movies they're probably going
to be a lot of additional scenes or
they're just going to expand on certain
scenes in the book so i'll be posting
more behind the scenes info and cool
videos for desolation smog as we get
closer to the movie be sure to subscribe
to get it i'm also doing season for
previews for Game of Thrones right now
so be sure and check those out to my
next one comes on Thursday I'll also be
doing a funny fathers day video for Game
of Thrones on Wednesday but it's really
just the best worst ads on Game of
Thrones spoiler alert it's thien's dad
also be sure and send me your questions
for desolation of smaug and i'll try to
answer them in my next video in the
meantime you can check out my game of
thrones season for previews by clicking
here and you can check out Benedict
Cumberbatch and Sherlock series 3 by
clicking here thanks for watching high
fives for dragons
you